هذا الطقس هو بالضبط سبب وجود
مثل هذا الشعور بالإلحاح عندما يتعلق الأمر
بمحاولة إخراج الأولاد
ومدربهم عندما كنا نتحدث إلى أحد
الغواصين الذي كان يقول أن أضيق
جزء يجب عليهم القيام به في
مهمة الإنقاذ هذه  يبلغ عرضه حوالي 80 سم ،
لذا لنفترض أن عرضه قدمين ونصف ، أي
ما يعادل حجم هذه الفتحة تقريبًا
، وعليهم محاولة التنقل في
ذلك أثناء وجوده تحت الماء ، ولا يتعلق
الأمر فقط بالحركة عبر
المساحات الضيقة حتى تلك العريضة التي تشكل مساحة
خاصة بهم  مجموعة من التحديات أعني كما
ترون هنا بوضوح أن سطح الصخور
غير متساوٍ بشكل لا يصدق في بعض
الحالات تمامًا من الغواصين والخبراء
الذين تحدثت شبكة CNN وآخرون عنهم جميعًا بالإجماع إلى
حد كبير
أن هذه واحدة من
أصعب مهام الإنقاذ  أن أيًا
منهم كان جزءًا منه ، يصبح نوعًا من
الشدة عندما تعود إلى هنا ، إنه
ضيق حقًا ، هذا ماء راكد
لا يتحرك خلاله وربما
لا يكون في أي مكان  بالقرب من غامضة مثل
ما سيضطر الغواصون والأولاد
إلى المرور من خلاله ، لكن إذا غمرنا
في الماء بضوء وحاولنا
تكرار الرؤية أو عدم وجودها
، قيل لنا إن الأمر يتعلق بقدم
للمسؤولين التايلانديين  قال إن الأولاد
تمكنوا من الوصول إلى المياه النظيفة عن طريق
شرب ما كان يقطر على
جوانب الكهف الآن هم بالطبع
في ظلام دامس ولا
يعرفون متى أو ما إذا كانوا
سيخرجون أحياء وهذه
محنة مرعبة  حتى أن الكبار
يجب أن يمروا بغض النظر عن طفل
، والتحدي الكبير في الوقت الحالي
لن يكون مجرد التعافي جسديًا
من هذه المحنة ولكن نفسية أيضًا
أروى ديمون ترى آنا الجوع أنا تايلاند